I woke up around 8:00 in Chicago on my
friend Shannon's couch couch sleeping is
the best sleeping a borrowed Chan's
toothbrush sorry Shannon was an
emergency restored the couch to its
former glory and then hit the road why
do I Drive a station wagon cuz I'm a
boss I was headed to a Book Festival in
wha pack at Wisconsin but first I had to
drive through Chicago which has always
been my favorite American city a city of
so many neighborhoods that you can never
discover them all a city as Carl
Sandburg wrote under the terrible burden
of destiny laughing as a young man
laughs by the way that place has great
produce I made it to the highway and
then drove north for three-hours along
the way and all at once became fall then
I finally made it to walk pack a city of
six thousand people with three
independent bookstores a librarian had
recommended I visit this place called
Brainard's Bridge Park and so I headed
straight there because I have found over
the years that librarians make excellent
recommendations and the park was no
exception there was this beautiful river
and this tree that refused to stop being
a tree despite considerable challenges
and then I found this walking path two
roads diverged in a yellow wood and I I
took the road more traveled by because I
did not want to get lost in wall Packer
Wisconsin I walked for a long time it
was really beautiful
and there I was awash in the majesty of
it all thinking I need to pee and I
can't decide if I'm adequately in the
woods right now to fee here or if I need
to go back to the park and find a
bathroom
so yeah just for the record I ended up
walking back to the park restroom I'm
gonna go ahead and wager that this
person has Elvis flags for most of the
major holidays so I drove over to apakah
High School to speak this is all voice
over so you can say whatever you want
and someone gave me a cheesehead which
was nice it was weird to talk to people
after having spent 10 hours by myself
but it always makes me really happy to
see for instance a handmade dftba shirt
assigned books for a while and then went
to the amazing Oaxaca public libraries
amazing teen room where there is a
poster of you on the wall and a space
for gaming and a chandelier the plain
term usek
they've only ever eaten some teens and I
played this incredibly complicated game
of bunny murdering and then I went to a
fancy cocktail party for the festival
where I met up with noted positive prank
or Amy cross Rosenthal who's organizing
this event
when Amy 10-10-10 at 10:10 p.m. at the
bean sculpture in Chicago it's a kind of
sequel to 8808 I'll be there playing a
very minor role if you want to learn how
to participate click the screen or read
all about it in the doobly-doo anyway it
was a great party but at one point a 91
year old woman got sick and an ambulance
came and took her off to the hospital
for maybe half an hour after the
ambulance came it was quiet and then it
got louder and then loud her skill as
all of us under the terrible burden of
destiny found a way to keep laughter
bedtime Hank I'll see you on Wednesday